-What happens now moving forward
in terms of, I mean,
first and foremost,
these separated families?
Do you have any optimism that
those 2,000 children
are gonna be reunited with
their parents?
-I hold out optimism,
if only because I think that
the public pressure
has had some effect.
Perversely, as you mentioned at
the top of the show,
there's now this, kind of,
choice that's being offered,
which is, like,
you can get your kid back
if you agree to be deported
and you renounce all your --
your claims to asylum.
So, I think a lot of people
are gonna be deport--
reunited that way.
But it's going to take
sustained public pressure.
I mean, what's very clear is,
we broke a story a year ago
when they first started
thinking about this policy.
And they thought about it
and they crafted
internal procedures about it.
And someone leaked us documents,
'cause there was this --
-This is the separation policy.
-Child separation policy.
People were so freaked out
about it
and they cogitated about it for
a year, and they implemented it.
They had no plan to reunite
these families.
They had no plan,
because they didn't care.
I mean, that's what, I think,
is so shocking
about this whole thing.
-How did it go from -- I mean,
so, 2017 you break this story.
Obviously, it takes, you know,
up to near a year
to come through.
Were there people
in the administration
who knew it would play
like this?
-I think so. And I think the
reason it didn't happen was,
precisely, because
the experts who --
you know,
there are people who work in
the Department
of Homeland Security
and in the asylum office
and things like this
who understand
that you can't do this.
And I think they warned
against it successfully.
I think the President in a fit
of pique, recently,
has been ramped up about how,
you know, stressed out he is
about the border.
-Yeah.
-And the "invasion"
and the "infestation"
that's coming over it,
and I think he managed to
prevail on his advisers
against a lot of the better
judgment of the civil servants
in those agencies
to start doing this.
-So, then he signs
an executive order, you know,
which ostensibly says,
"We're gonna get these families
back together."
He says, you know, on
television, he just couldn't --
it was too awful to have
families be separated.
What do you think happened there
for him
to ultimately reverse himself?
Although we are hearing
whispers now
that he's saying he wishes
he hadn't done that.
-I think the President
sits in the White House
and watches cable news all day.
-Yeah. Good for you.
[ Laughter ]
-Good for us, maybe.
Bad for the country probably.
-Yeah, yeah.
Probably not a -- probably
not a ton of MSNBC.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Although, yes.
Although he -- more than I think
he would ever admit.
-Right, right. Yeah.
-You know what I mean?
Like, there's times
where it's very clear --
he does a lot of hate-watching.
-Yeah.
-Which, again, if you're
hate-watching, cool.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You know, whatever --
I don't judge.
-They all have to
watch the commercials.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
-We make no discernment.
No, I mean, basically, I think
he's sitting there
and he's watching himself
take a beating on this
in public opinion and feels like
he has to walk it back.
And I thought it was
a significant moment
in the history of
this administration
because we've seen him penned in
before by the courts, you know,
when they came in against
the travel ban or DACA.
We've seen him penned in by
Congress when John McCain
gave the thumbs-down for ACA.
This was really the first time
that I felt like civil society,
you know, in -- in a broad
sense, basically, kind of,
stood up and said,
"No, you can't do this."
-You mentioned civil society.
I will segue to civility.
That seems to be
the conversation today.
It's a tricky thing to talk
about, because I think we all,
you know, we all would expect
to be treated civilly.
Like, we all want that.
How do you feel about right now
Republicans saying
that there is now
a lack of civility?
-I mean, look, I under--
I want to, like, acknowledge
what you're saying, which is
I get people's impulse.
And I don't think it's a bad
impulse to have of, like,
"Yeah, don't yell at people."
Or, be, you know -- I get that.
That's a human and
understandable part of
people's impulses
around this stuff.
And, generally, I think that's
a good guiding post for people.
I will say this that,
look, Sarah Huckabee Sanders,
for example, is one of the most
powerful people in the world.
And in a very real and tangible
sense the defining feature of
a free society
is that you can tell
one of the most powerful people
in the world in your government,
"Get out of my restaurant."
-Right.
-Like, that's genuinely, like, a
thing that makes a free society.
[ Applause ]
And, now, people could say,
like, that --
I don't think they should
do that or that's rude.
And I totally get people
on either side of that.
But in a real deep sense, like,
hectoring, yelling at
public officials?
I mean, I covered all the
Tea Party town halls of 2009.
That was a festival of yelling
at public officials.
And in the same way,
that's actually
an important right to preserve.
So I think sometimes that this
conversation about civility
can paper over a lot of
what is actually just --
what politics looks like.
-And, you know, I feel, like,
lost in this, obviously,
Sarah Huckabee Sanders,
in her tweet, framed her --
she focused on her own
politeness in politely leaving.
It does seem as though she was
also politely asked to leave.
-Yes.
-Now, again, you know,
at the end of the day,
I think if you're asked to leave
a restaurant
you don't look back and go,
"They were so nice about it."
[ Laughter ]
-They did -- They did comp them
the cheese plate.
-Yes. That's no small thing.
-Yeah.
But, you know, and it did strike
me as interesting that the woman
who owned the restaurant,
she went and asked her staff.
She made it very clear that
she had, you know,
she had an ethnic staff, she had
a staff that were, you know --
gay people on her staff
that made it difficult.
And she actually asked them
their opinion, which --
-I thought it was, look, again,
I feel like the basic --
my basic principles here are --
nonviolent action
in dissent or in protest,
sort of across viewpoints,
is part of what American
political life is about.
And, you know, that's --
[ Applause ]
That's like -- and I think --
And I think people feeling moral
urgency about a 12-month-old
who is sitting in some facility
a thousand miles away
from her mother,
who's been torn away from her,
I think feeling some sense that,
like, this is a crisis.
This is a moral crisis
that requires me
to take
some extra action, again,
within the sort of confines of,
you know, what's protected
under law and our democratic,
sort of, principles.
I think that
that makes a lot of sense.
-It's always so great
to have you here.
Thank you so much
for making the time for us.
-Thank you, man.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Chris Hayes, everybody.